[Music]
good evening everyone my name is Jackson
I work as an engineer for slack and so I
like to say no day - no problem
you got no data you got no problems to
solve yeah hey my name is Alan
I work as a monitoring infrastructure
team along with Jackson yeah no - no
problem but unfortunately that is not
the way the real world works
and often you end up with lot of partial
data and that is the cost of most of the
problem and that's how we employed and
our talk is also about how are you going
to solve this partial problems through
the top so first we'll sort of talk a
little bit outside and we are a public
watch in 2014 and we have 1500 employees
across ten offices in seven countries
and we target a diverse set of
industries we target obviously the
technology industry but also media and
retail telecoms and professional
services we have about 10 million daily
active users and 85,000 paying customers
of the Fortune 100 companies 65 of those
our customers and we're in 150 different
countries with 15,000 apps in our app
directory and so we're here to talk
about events and event pipelines so sort
of talking about what an event is and
you can think of an event is like a
single occurrence within an environment
usually involving an attempted state
change and this can be something like
incoming HTTP request or a cache look up
and usually via so to associate these
with sometime
usually some effect from the state or
some calls for that state change and we
can collect these events into logs and
so in the case of like an HTTP request
the log would look like you have your
client IP address may have your request
path and all of that is what makes up
the HTTP request and we'll use these
logs to answer our critical business
questions we can say okay what went
wrong why did these things go wrong and
we also have a notion of log producers
and law consumers soul our producers
naturally are the things that produce
the logs and in log consumers are the
things that consume the logs and people
and machines can both be log producers
and law consumers and a lot of times
they're doing this at the same time so
in we often see that like a single log
or a single log event can be used to
enter many different questions in
different contexts and so we use this
data to get an understanding about the
current state of our systems and our
services and once we get a good
understanding of the current state we
can use this too and have better
informed actions on the next steps we
want to take or better informed
understanding of where the service might
be headed so to give a little info about
logging at slack we have about 3 million
events per second or P congestion and we
queue those events onto for individual
coffee clusters and at our peak were
processing about 3 terabytes of data per
hour so I want to give an example of how
we use some of the logs at slack we do
the fair billing policy which means that
we only build users when they come
online and so it's very important for us
to capture
when a user becomes active in a psych
team because we can't do that then we
can't accurately build and we also use
our logs to measure our service quality
its selects mission to make to make work
life productive and pleasant in order to
do this we need to make sure that slack
is a reliable service it should be
available whenever and wherever our
users need it and so we can use these
logs and metrics to measure the
availability and status of our service
so here I'm showing a picture of our
basically where we started without a
logging infrastructure we had a we had
our application it would write to two
services our syslog and one called Bruce
and what Bruce would do is it take data
and a binary protocol and write it
directly to Kafka from there we had a
service called C core that would take
the data pack it into hourly buckets and
write that to s3
once it's in s3 it's ready for our data
warehouse to ingest but we also had to
deal with system logs and text logs so
those good to go through our sis our
path our syslog writes the data to our
elasticsearch cluster elasticsearch
would take the syslog or take the text
logs parse them with regex
or grott patterns format them into a
kind of semi structured document and
write that to elasticsearch which we use
for log search occasionally we would
find that we need some text logs in our
data warehouse so we have like our
syslog writing into Kafka and then
through C core and then into s3 and so
if you kind of get like this complex
math of pipelines going on and the big
problem is is it reliable so first we
had two different logging pipelines here
and it calls a big maintenance headache
we didn't know if we lost any data
during transit if there's an outage we
didn't know how much data we lost
you know if we have like a 10-minute
outage on our on Bruce or if coffee goes
down we have no idea if we lost three
terabytes of data or we were able to
recover all the data and we didn't know
if our logging pipeline was secure we
didn't have room for secure protocols in
our pipeline and when it comes to
billing data that becomes very important
and we also knew Bruce worked well but
it was a black box for us and we didn't
really understand how it worked
internally so we decided to start new
and build a new logging pipeline and we
wanted to identify what's important in
this pipeline so we came up with four
characteristics
the first being trust in logs we wanted
to make sure that our developers can use
our log pipeline and be confident that
their log units are going to make it
into the database and that they can
query this database and be able to use
the results from the logs and you know
on top of that some of their critical
pipelines in order to prefer to rely on
our logging pipeline so it's not good
enough to say oh we had an outer join
lost data when we lose data we want to
be able to say this is how much data we
missed right this is where we lost the
data and this is the time window where
we were losing data these together will
allow us to minimize the impact of data
loss naturally also on a high
availability in your event pipeline so
for those that means we'll use fault
tolerant protocols and we want the
system to automatically retry on
failures and finally we want to make
sure that we can ingest logs when our
parts of the logging infrastructure are
offline so as I said before we ingest
logs into Kafka for queue but
what happens when coffee goes offline
we're gonna make sure that we can still
ingest logs and from the log producer
side nothing has changed
so next we need low latency low latency
is very important because we decided
that the time to insight should be in
milliseconds our critical systems depend
on these metrics so we need to be able
to you know have the latest data so you
can respond accordingly
and most importantly we know that the
value of data exponentially decreases as
time moves on and finally we need an
efficient system we want minimum
computation and storage far as resource
usage is concerned and we want the
system to run with a minimal operational
overhead and then on top of that we're
tenants of business systems so we don't
want to spend too many hosts resources
on ingesting logs and finally we realize
that when we're emitting some of these
log events we're sending them through
multiple pipeline basically the same
data through multiple pipelines to get
into different endpoints and so we
wanted to leverage Kafka's consumer
framework so we can send the data once
to Kafka and then have consumers and
jessa as they need it take objective so
as the Jackson mentioned just to recap
like we took a step back and see like
what it really mean to build a date up
pipeline before us so wanted how a
trusting locks low latency high
available efficient system but how do
you do that
so in order to bring a trusting data we
need to capture a lot of metadata
information around when it is originated
who or generated the event how it is
getting transformed across the pipeline
we cannot expect our application
developers or the log producers to give
us all the metadata information so what
we come up we created a protocol called
modern protocol so modern protocol is
essentially a set of metadata fields
it's a protocol format
so any application developers are any
system logs they wanted to ship logs to
a pipeline essentially use the protocol
to package their logs and send that one
right so we have the following fields
time stamp is a UNIX timestamp it's
essentially says like when the event is
originated right and the host is
essentially what is a host that
generated a log and type it supposedly
says the type of the log let's say an
example of Apache access is like an
access log there might be a kubernetes
logs are like a different application
system generate different types of logs
so type essentially says who owns the
data like who is the producer of the
data in a single force that will be
multiple application can run so the type
distinguish who is the actual water of
this log and the offset a offset is a
very important property here offset is
an incremental sequence number generator
third type so when when an application
write events to our even pipeline we
generate an incremental sequence number
if for each and every type so we do this
for a reason because downstream in
anywhere in our even pipeline we can
essentially reconstruct the whole even's
and we can see where is the missing
sequence and we can reliably say where
we miss the data here and there's a PID
is a process ID because process can
always die and can restart when it is
restored it can it reset the offset so
we wanted to make sure the offset and
the PID combined the unique
identification of this incremental
sequence number then there's a message
message is the actual payload it could
be an Apache access log or any business
metrics that people send and the
signature
the actual talk about like how slack the
users are logs to powers building stands
in the matrix it is very those of the
metrics actually get reported to the
wall street so we don't want we wanted
to be make sure that
none of the system in the middle can
tamper the business metrics so we
implement as a signature feature
assistance to provide this functionality
and finally there is a tax tax it's just
a key value path we added this because
we notice that some of the application
like let's say some applications on some
coupon it is they wanted to add more
metadata information like what kind of a
container image they running in what is
the cube image is running in is there
any container reversion they add at that
so they can add all those other related
relevant metadata information along with
the payload not necessarily directly
correlated with the application but
those infrastructure met metadata
information might be useful for some
consumers downstream so the mod protocol
essentially a very flexible way to
enforce certain standard how do we ship
our logs into a pipeline so take a deep
dive on this so you can see the
timestamp host type offset and PID all
those five dimensions if you take that
is a unique identification of a event
you can globally identify a particular
even when when it is generated so you
can add they bought a property of this
UID you can reconstruct the whole pipe
hole even generation at any point of a
time and you can replay and understand
how does the transformation happen what
is happening through the even pipeline
so that's how we build trust in the logs
what we say essentially it is literally
impossible to build a pipeline that will
not lose any data we we are not
guaranteeing like hunter college
reliability but what we can teen is that
if you do if you lost any data in them
in in the in the middle we can give you
a high visibility and we can give you
what percentage and then and where we
lost the event so when the producers or
the consumers trying to make a business
critical decision they can make with
operate confident based on our metrics
so the message and signature our stock
report the business critical metrics so
what this what is happening here the
producers use H Mack signature like I
certainly do H my encryption on the
message create a signature and add the
signature along with the payload so in
the downstream pipeline before we put
those data into data warehouse we create
the same H match signature and validate
whether the signatures matches or not if
the signature doesn't match us we can
assume that something happen in the
middle some alteration happen we drop
those message we will not end up in the
data warehouse so that who don't build
twice or who don't do a pulse building
on top of it so that's essentially a
rough design of modern protocol the
protocol is nice but it is still a very
concept well design right we still need
to build a high available low latency
system on top of the modern protocol in
order to really build this even pipeline
so we started working on on the
infrastructure part of it
right so this is sort of the concept of
even sourcing as a service so this is
this components essentially provided in
even sourcing as a service so three
components are important in this in this
design one is like modern agent and
modern so and even TQ so we use Kafka as
a given Q but I am NOT going to talk
about a lot about tough guys like Kafka
is there for us as an even Q for that so
drill back on modern agent so what is
what is modern age and what is really
doing that modern it is like a nice
little demon that stands on each and
every host of slack circus-like
instances so if you provision a new
server in slack
modern agent installed automatically
it's just run as a site card for you and
it listen to a unique socket domain so
anyone wanted to write a locks
they just keep right into the UNIX
socket of mine
and send the logs to these things so
once a modern agent receives a payload
and it happened it wrap other metadata
information that we noticed in the
modern protocol it at time Sam it act
like what is the host which is generated
it's try adding an incremental offset
sequence number and it had what is the
type of the message and the process ID
so it's add all the other metadata
information and wrap in a container and
then just push that one by container I
mean like modern protocol I'm using as a
container here
so that's not all enough because the
downstream is never be reliable the
downstream can always file like Kafka
can fail what will happen if modern
agent not able to send the data right
and it's already just happen all the
time so how do we and it's either it can
run on a downgraded mode or it could be
completely unavailable so that
essentially create a back pressure on to
the source system so modern agents
should support and observe the back
pressure from whatever the upstream
failures happened so maroon agent has a
concept of queuing it support two queues
one is like disk assistant queue so what
happened is that if it is not able to
write any events to the upstream it
started to write to our disk assistant
queue and once the upstream available
again it will replay from the queue and
thereby guarantee that minimizes the
data loss in front of the things so that
is one failure cases where what upstream
failed and the other failure case is
like what if the modern agent itself
failed what if what if the application
not able to write to modern agent so
modern agents provide a managed to queue
so managed q is nothing but a wrapper we
build it around a file system so if an
application not able to write to a
modern age and it will just write to a
managed queue when modern agent
available again it will again reap
from our managed queue system so those
discusses will queue and managed queue
is essentially the same concept we build
it on the same astra abstraction thereby
we provide like no matter if an upstream
is not available or what even the modern
agent is not available the application
is still able to lock the events into
inter or even pipeline so that's how we
kind of solved providing more fault
tolerance when the even sourcing part of
it and then those small relationship the
logs to modern server so modern server
is a nice G RPC service that accept
events from modern agent and other
external clients what I mean by other
external clients is that modern agents
is a nice little demon but friend can
run only on us slack instances but slack
is available on all the mobile devices
so what if a mobile device not able to
connect to slide service they still need
to able to send hey I am NOT able to
connect and that's a critical metrics
that we need to do that so modern so it
can add sub-matrix from other external
clients if they're able to communicate
to the modern agent side right so modern
agent provide much more than that it is
essentially a routing framework for us
I'll explain the routing framework on
the next slide and the modern server
essentially gathered those information
and then pass onto Kafka or any other
even cue system that we do that
so so what is so let's take a deep dive
on like modern silver like how the
snorting protocol works when we started
to develop this even pipeline as Jackson
mentioned that what we notice is that a
producer comes that can be one producer
can be consumed by multiple consumers
and wanted to be they can interpret
those messages in a multiple way like no
deer like business I say take an example
of a patchy access log a Business
Analytics can see Apache access rock in
a different perspective versus the
operational analytics see in a different
perspective on a different
transformation of a thing so we often
end up multiplexing the same events
across the different pools and we also
noticed that let's say business-critical
data that needs to be go to be more
highly secured Kafka cluster versus the
event log or any Apache access log that
doesn't require that level of security
and like other authentication on top of
it so different locks and different
types has a different need and hid a
different interpretation throughout the
downstream right so the routing protocol
essentially says oh this is a type of a
message can goes to a secure box secure
pure secret pool and goes to less secure
pool or high throughput pool so you can
configure a same message to be delivered
to multiple destination of pools so
that's essentially controlled in our
routing layer and this is completely a
configuration driven we can dynamically
add those configuration to change the
way the flow of those individual life
flowing through those things and this
this routing protocol comes very handy
for us whenever we do upgrade of
upstream system let's say you do we
recently did like from Kafka zero point
eleven to two point zero and the upgrade
was seamless is because we just spin off
another cluster and add another routing
a routing rule for our types and just
end up in the cockatoo clusters and it's
easy for us to do migrations and
upstream failures so that's about the
modern protein protocol so then so with
this model agent and modern so we talked
about a lot about infrastructure like
how the events originated and how it is
that are getting it out there but if you
drill down an event and even has a life
cycle on its won't even get produced by
a producer and then it goes to some kind
of a transformation let's take an
example of Apache access log it's a
simple text file and then we need to
like let's say Apache access log we want
to be ingest into elasticsearch
elasticsearch accept JSON documents and
we need to convert that talk over like
Apache access log into a JSON format so
you apply some croc parsing in the
middle and and in the even that you
realize like most of the lots are HTTP
200 is less important or less
interesting logs to index and you wanted
to drop or sample some HTTP status code
200 and then ingest that but in data
warehouse perspective you want like all
the logs to give full corrective
analytical solutions so the event itself
goes through a different life cycle just
like how we drove so we wanted to
capture that life cycle also so we come
up with an modern a doctor so adapter
essentially an an adopter for intercept
a life cycle of an event and you can
write a very generic extra like a very
generic life cycle event on top of it
like both the data warehouse and the
elasticsearch required Apache access to
be in the JSON format so there is no
point of converting into converting in
two different places you can write on
modern adopter that essentially convert
your apache' access to a JSON format and
all the other downstream consumer can
reuse the same thing right so that's
that's what the modern adopters all
those about so complaining complaining
our modern agent model so end of modern
adopter patterns this is where we end up
this is our current state of a system
our even pipeline so you can see there
are there are setup agents sending the
message to a server and Kafka is having
in the a given Q for us and and we have
set of consumer sessions Lee
implementing a event lifecycle for those
things so we talked about the
reliability crisis that we had it
earlier and we we indeed create a replay
the whole event and we created what we
call the reliability index score and we
plotted it and you can choose a type and
we can say what is the reliability index
score of a particular event to give a
lot of to gain more confident to our
users to get more vegetable be on top of
it and some of the things that will
cheer like some part of a time get your
hundred percentage of reliable even
pipelines on stock offices so they so
fine like what is next like what are we
working on now how are you going to
improve the system the number one is
modern DAP modern we call it like direct
acyclic blueprint it's essentially says
if you take up at modern agent and
modern server talks a lot about
infrastructure and then we talked about
the event lifecycle ability to write a
pipeline and the infrastructure as a
code is a very very powerful feature and
that will give a power to our users
without worrying about how to spin off
an infrastructure how to manage our
event life cycle they can create the
pipeline on the wound and manage that
one so the vision of modern DAP is to
get to a stage where we give a DSL
to our end users to create their own
pipeline and infrastructure and manage
by themselves this one burned a problem
watch and intelligent sing in the
industry there's lot of lot of talk
about in the streaming world about how
do we manage later having data you know
how to manage watermark period and all
those things but in all practical life
what we notice that what will happen if
an upstream sink is degraded more like a
not performing class that is slow for
some time but the application developer
wanted to see the latest log they don't
wanted to wait for the degraded service
to be up and running again and what we
really noticed that a latency watermark
is a biggest thing in our even pipeline
we should trait we should have a low
tolerance for violating they're late
violating the latency watermark the
modern backfill idea is that if you
notice that there is a events violating
a latency watermark we advance the
pipeline to the current event and create
an automatic backfill infrastructure to
slowly consume the the lag data into the
system so we promise or we we can keep
the system up and running and always up
to date it reflect the current state of
our application servers not the five
minutes delay of the systems there so
that's that's an idea behind auto back
pain and the schema has a service like
even though we captured a lot of semi
structured information often it is
important to describe what is the event
what is what is the payload look like
that would be very helpful to create a
very generic adopters down the pipeline
can be reusable across all the all the
pipelines so we are working on a schema
as a service or shut off of things so
yeah that's about it
we are planning or thinking to open
source this if any of the things for
interest rate ryu come talk
we can thank you hey thanks for the talk
so it sounded especially with the last
slide now like maybe you are thinking
about taking this approach of
standardizing a bit different ways of
streaming basically related kinds of
data are you planning on taking the same
approach to other parts of your data so
now this is for logging but then also
for all of the other types of data that
go through the system yes yes that's
right like this even pipeline initially
started for lots but now we are and we
are optic traces now and we are also
getting into matrix now so our goal is
to support all three format of
monitoring pillars and then these are
the important property that we wanted to
give everyone to go out there so yeah we
are extending our support other things
as far as like traces and metrics we
actually we ingest Prometheus metrics as
a remote storage in point in our and
then we've also ingest traces as well do
you think that it's beneficial to
upstream some of like this work for
example systemd has binary locks and
they could benefit from your ideas about
with like having his mandatory fields
and those so that all basically Linux
like instances who run like or something
like systemd
would benefit from you're having like
incremental ID knees or something like
that so do you think it's beneficial to
be maybe upstream like that format or
something like that yeah to those like
projects I'm sorry what is the system
system D basically like Linux funny you
know as far as like so as we feel like
merge so we can receive the events
through G RPC
for the most part we don't assume that
when we get the G RPC events they're
gonna have the offset and we expected
the hostname is field but like the the
rest of the Eid we don't assume that
it's going to be populated so when Marin
server receives the events if it doesn't
have these fields it will auto auto
populate them but we also we also try to
like encourage people that are sending
the logs through your PC to go ahead and
do that because if they set that offset
from from their client then that means
like when we if we do lose the data we
can track it back and say okay here's
the offset it orange originated and your
server from this point before it even
reached our infrastructure and I think
the same applies for system D as well if
system D did have that kind of
incremental offset and sent it to to us
in our pipeline that way we could
similarly trace it back okay here's
where it failed in the system D pipeline
so yeah it's a short yeah definitely my
question would be how do you manage
dynamic mapping fields regarding the
elastic search in this case of might be
that in some way well always this
problem within the elastic search
depending on how many fields cousins on
system either you have a strict mapping
definition or a dynamic one in this case
which one are you using and lease in
case regarding the language so we use
dynamic ramping in elastic search and
it's definitely a pain point for us and
something we're trying to figure out
part of over eternity with this scheme
as a service is we want to as far as
elastic search ingestion we want to say
you know you send us all the fields that
you want but tell us which fields are
important to you in which fields need
the type safety and then that way we can
enforce them in the elastic search side
but yeah we definitely right now we're
using the dynamic type mapping and is
definitely a pain point for us
and regarding conflicts because the
things that depending on which service
we want to represent it so I've seen
promo sales over there so it might be
that you might be also using Gravano but
at least within service like within
cabana with canvas has sometimes some
problems regarding conflict due to some
issues with the MEP mapping of certain
fields in this case how do you deal with
that so right now we don't have such a
at least because we have the type field
so we index on the type field so as long
as generally only one application is
going to send the same type of logs like
two applications shouldn't be sending
the same type of log and so as long as
that application doesn't emit bad logs
for it's like changing the field it's
usually fine but in cases where we do
have the type field collision we just
drop the logs you don't bother trying to
index it into Lassiter because it can't
really handle it
[Music]